hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast writing the NIH ro1
research grant strategies for success
presented by dr. Christopher dance
president and owner of medCom consulting
I'm Christy Jewell of lab rats and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminars brought
to you by lab roots and sponsored by
Leica Microsystems for more information
on our sponsor please visit mica
Microsystems comm now let's get started
I would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them in the ask a question
box and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have climbed four at the
end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of your
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box this presentation is
educational MS offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit
I'd now like to introduce our presenter
dr. Christopher dant dr. Dan is a PhD
trained investigator and consultant in
the biomedical field few lectures and
consults widely in academia and Industry
on manuscript writing NIH and NSF career
in research grants and basic scientific
writing skills for scientists his
business medCom consulting serves
academic clients to review and write NIH
grants as well as peer-reviewed
manuscripts for a complete biography on
our speaker please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen dr. Dan
you may now begin your presentation
good day
today focuses on writing the research
grant from the National Institutes of
Health the NIH one of the most
sought-after and popular sources of
medical research funding in the world
and it's from an institute that has
funded scientists that have received
world recognized accolades and Nobel
prizes for their groundbreaking
achievements in medical science the
information that I'm going to present
today is from my many years of over 20
or 30 years of experience in working
with investigators at academic centers
in the United States and presents
information and advice that has been
vetted by the NIH itself and many
professors who have one ro1 and K or
career grants from the NIH
perhaps many of you have written a grant
but probably a lot of you have not
written one and or even know the
specifics of the NIH and their grant
system but I want to let you know that
the background is specific material I'm
going to present today is vital for
anyone in academia whether you're a lab
technician a biologist a student of PhD
students a postdoctoral fellow a junior
or senior faculty or even an
administrator working in the field of
grants because the information will
frame how you consider plan carry out
and communicate your research if you
conduct any radical medical research you
first have to understand how to
communicate not only your methods and
results but more importantly why you are
conducting the research in the first
place its rationale its significance and
how it is unique and innovative and most
importantly how your findings will
impact the future of research with a
goal of uncovering the mysteries of
science that have eluded us to this
point and ultimately improving the lives
of people throughout the world and it is
all these considerations that are
encapsulated within the NIH research
grant and I'm going to discuss today I
would just say that in my experience the
reason grant writing is so difficult for
investigators is because scientists have
not considered many of these important
aspects of the research in the first
place the corollary of that or the flip
side of that is the people who have
thought a lot about how to communicate
the research its rationale and
significance the impact it has they find
grant writing fairly easy because that
is what the grant contains at the heart
of it framing your thinking about your
research will greatly further your
academic career by showing you how to
communicate with your colleagues at
medical congresses how to write an
accepted peer review manuscript and a
winning grant whether it's from the NIH
or the National Science Foundation
NSF or other federal agencies or from
any of the hundreds of private
foundations such as the Gates Foundation
or Howard Hughes Medical Institute
all of which fund millions of dollars of
research each year but it'll also
advance your career by funding and
communicating your research in a way
that not only stands out to those who
listen to your lectures but also to your
colleagues who read we have written in
your field so let me begin with that
background a corollary of what I just
said is writing is extremely important
writing and communicating you know a
foundation in science and medical
research is very as essential is very
important and that is what your training
has given you but equally important and
often ignored and not taught is clear
writing disorganized and sloppy writing
is interpreted by reviewers as
disorganized thinking and sloppy
research I used to be and a editor for
the senior editor for JAMA or the
Journal of American Medical Association
I can tell you that no matter how good
the research is if the paper is poorly
put together is sloppy
it is reflects very badly on on the
person who submitted it and the success
or failure of your academic position is
directly linked to clearly communicating
with science in both written and oral
formats so do understand even though it
may be obvious that your grant or your
manuscript is the only representation of
your work to those who matter the
reviewers and editors so this is
extremely important to understand in the
consideration of writing a grant but in
general your career as well
so my mantra for a grant or what they
call a grantsmanship is there really is
no grantsmanship or ability to write a
good grant that will turn a bad
scientific idea into a good one but
there are many ways to disguise a good
scientific idea and this is the heart of
what i'm going to present today is how
not to disguise it very important
so I'll talk about what the NIH era when
grant is the research grant and I want
to do the bulk of my talk will be about
the strategy for writing the grant and
then I'll talk a little bit about peer
reviewers those who review your grants
and their application and their points
of good grant writing and a little bit
about organizing the grant and some
aesthetics and writing
so first the NIH and some of you I'm
sure know the NIH quite well have seen
many other websites but those who don't
just let me introduce the unites the say
it's the large ik largest public funder
of medical research biomedical research
in the world in in invest over thirty
two billion dollars a year in research
to enhance life and reduce illness and
disability and the NIH has funded
research that have led to breakthrough
you know new treatments help people who
live longer healthier lives and built
the research foundation that dries
discovery and that last point is
extremely important because not
necessarily all NIH research is directly
linked to health and human disease but
it's also uncovering new discoveries in
in many different fields that that drive
research forward and for example the
National Institute of General Medical
Sciences NIGMS is an institute that that
does basic science in cellular and
cellular biology and molecular biology
in many other fields but not necessarily
directly linked to disease
at the NIH there are 27 institutes many
of you know these institutes the the
really familiar ones the big big ones of
the National Cancer Institute the
National Heart Lung and Blood Institute
NHLBI the National Institute of Allergy
and Infectious Diseases that is really
really an important one the National
Institute of Diabetes and digestive and
kidney diseases and a DDK the Institute
of General Medical Sciences I just
mentioned the National Institute of
Mental Health or NIH and the National
Institute of neurological diseases and
Stroke and I MDS those are the big
tickets at the NIH there's quite a few
others all of which have their own
flavor and I would say that if you are
specifically interested in particular
Institute in a field of research that
you're in to look at go to that
Institute or Center on in the you know
on the NIH website and each one is
different it has its own mission their
own budgets their own activities their
ways of doing things it's a very
individual personality in other words
the NIH Institute websites are not
uniform they're all very different and
before you would submit a grant it is
extremely important that you would check
with any program directors from the
Institute's to determine their policies
and interest in your science that is
probably the most vital piece of
information I can give you because I
have worked with many many investigators
and was on the faculty at Dartmouth and
at Stanford University and I've worked
with investigators on their grants and I
have seen them write a grant for a
specific Institute submit it and have it
rejected saying well this is not the
kind of grant that we fund you should
have checked with us first
you know the NCI does not fund this but
n I am a GMS or
niddk might be interested so it's very
important that you first check with
program directors
the r1 is the granddaddy of sort of the
original and historically the oldest
grant mechanism used by the NIH to
support research and development it has
what they call parent announcements and
I won't go into those too much but the
parent announcement means that it's it's
an unsolicited grant in other words it's
not solicited by the NIH I'll talk a
little bit about that in a minute they
have a specific PA number and you can
type this into Google PA 1844 and get
the announcement and read it one in
which no clinical trial or one in which
clinical trials requires so there are
two different announcements this
particular type of grant supports new
grants any renewals resubmissions
revisions whereas other our grants don't
allow that for example the ro3 and i'm
not going to talk a lot about that
there's a small research grant for only
two years and about $50,000 and it does
not support any of those just the new
grant the ro1 will pay some where the
order of five hundred thousand dollars
per year in direct cost for a four-year
grant has equals two million dollars
it's a lot of money to run a research
project
this is a pit of the mixed bag here this
grant this graph these are research
project grants RPGs for all institutes
and centers so it's not only the RO one
but the RO three the r21 the r34 there's
a slew of the our grants so this shows
success rates
how many grants were submitted how many
were accepted in overall all Institute's
all 27 institutes for all years from 19
2008 to 2017 it was about 16 and a half
percent success rate and that in the
success rates as an average have gone
down and come back up in the most recent
years I think in 2018 the number is
closer to sixteen point five but it's a
bit elusive because this is all research
project grants for all institutes and if
you will look at ro1 grant success rates
for say the National Institute or the
National Cancer Institute it would be 8%
pretty low whereas the National
Institute of General Medical Sciences is
more like about 18 percent they vary
quite a bit and that for a lot of
reasons and so add a version all is
about 16 prudence and a half percent
that means that an awful lot of grants
don't get accepted and I guess my point
of the slide is if you want to assure a
success rate in a field that is very
very highly competitive you have to know
how to write the grant in a way that's
going to get the reviewers attention and
be successful in presentation our grants
whether they be our twenty ones which is
a innovative research grant or ro3 or
small grant or an r1 they're all receipt
the fifth of the month of February June
and October in four months paths that a
review and Foreman
past that a start date so if it's a
renewal resubmission or revision the
dates are different but these are for
new applications so there are three
times during the year you can submit an
AR grant and in it our grant the
organization is shown here there are 16
different specific parts to the grant
and it's a very large it's a very large
document and today I'm going to talk to
you about sections 2 & 3 which are
really in my view the heart of the grant
and the introduction is really used only
for resubmission to resubmit a grant for
a specific reason but the specific games
in the research strategy are really the
heart of the grant I'm going to talk
about those exclusively when the NIH
reviews and scores your grant they use
five criteria and I'm going to talk
about at least three of these that are
important we'll touch on all five the
relevance to human health and disease
and that's the significance the
innovation is how original your approach
is the approach criteria is the
feasibility of your methods will it
answer the aims will they be feasible
you your investigator p.i training and
experience and the environment your
institution suitability of your
facilities and adequacy and support from
your specific institution and the
overall impact score which is from one
to nine for example an incident scores
that run from 10 to 90 attend being the
best in 90 being the worst is overall
reflects the likelihood for a project to
exert a sustained and powerful influence
on the research field is involved in
consideration of these criteria and
others there are often other criteria
but the
the main five and this is ni H's wording
the likelihood free for this research to
exert a powerful sustained influence on
the research field this is very
important that you think in a very high
way about your research in terms of
these things because if if you could not
stand in an elevator talking to a
colleague and saying bill tell me a
little bit about your research and
really hit the significance what why its
innovative how you're going to do it and
more importantly what impact it will
have then you really have no business
writing a grant or even giving a talk
about the research you're doing because
these are these are important aspects of
your research so impact is the word that
that I like to focus on because the
impact and priority score will reflect a
reviewers judgment of two broad concepts
importance in likelihood the first one
is the significance and innovation of
the research problem its ability to move
the field forward
the second one likelihood is the ability
that you the principle investigator can
achieve your ends is judged by the
design of your experiment the expertise
of your team what resources you have not
only in your lab but at your institution
to execute the project successfully and
your past successes which are reflected
in the grant that's reflected in in many
different parts of the grant and I'll
talk a little bit about where where that
is shown and at a 50,000 foot view your
overall impact score really is is my
research important or significant to
human health and disease plus can I do
it and i'ma qualified to do it plus will
it have a significant impact on the
field those are the three big areas that
I would say the NIH is looking for
the biosketch which is your curriculum
vitae in a sense but it's in a new form
actually they changed it a few years ago
this is a place where you get scored for
principal investigator including your
background what grants and publications
you've produced that are relevant to
your proposal your track record your
overall training and experience and
there's a personal statement that goes
in these and I can't tell you how
irritating it has been for me over my
career to see investigators taste
personal statements in every single
biosketch for every different grant that
they that they put forth every single
grant has a different different personal
statement about their role and their
ability to carry out this research in
this particular grant so every biosketch
in fact is going to be really unique to
some extent even though your backgrounds
the same the abstract that goes with a
grant has two parts which one is called
a project summary which is really the
abstract it's a succinct and accurate
description it's informative to other
persons working in the same field or
related fields and for it a technically
literate reader it's about 30 lines of
text the project narrative is the second
component that defines relevance and the
way that NIH describes it as they say no
more than two to three sentences scribe
the relevance of this research to human
health and this is used by Congress so
it's written in plain language and it's
two to three sentences a little while in
the lecture I'm going to talk to you
about using the NIH reporter which is
probably the most powerful tool you can
learn to pull up various abstracts from
funded research and I recommend that you
maybe pull up a few in your field and
read the project narratives that are in
them of the funded research because I
think it
we'll show you how the investigator has
thought through the relevance of the
research to Public Health it's it's
quite important and I think this is one
of the things that most reviewers read
when they when they get the grant
so the specific games this is really the
heart of the research grant why do I
intend to accomplish and why is it worth
funding
and one of my mentors at Stanford Alan
Reece who runs a huge research lab and I
used to be his grant person there used
to tell me most reviewers will read only
the aims in the abstract and make up
their minds about their proposal then
they'll look to the detail of your
proposal would support their opinion but
it'll be Ueno dressing for them if they
are not excited or think that this has
much merit so I would say that the
specific games is probably the most
important part of your grant and the NIH
asks for this and this is their language
right out of the instructions the sf-424
instructions state concisely the goals
of the proposed research and summarize
the expected outcomes and I underline
this part is including the impact that
the results of the proposed research
will exert on a research field as well
I find it incredulous that this is
written in the instructions and I used
to get pages of specific aims from
researchers that completely miss that so
this is really really really important
this last part then it says list the
objectives these are the aims are you
testing a stated hypothesis in almost
every case you will be are you creating
a novel design you're solving a specific
problem or you're challenging a paradigm
or clinical practice are you addressing
a critical barrier to progress in the
field or developing a new technology and
you may be doing every single one of
those six items but it helps to have
this in front of you when you're writing
your aims just to keep keep your keep
the framework in front of you so that
you know that you're I mean you you can
use those exact words you are going to
be writing a hypothesis you are using a
novel design hopefully and and you're
stating the specific problem but these
are what the NIH asked for
so there are four paragraphs to the to
the aims and that could be debated
however I can tell you the NIH has
vetted my slides and they certainly
agree with it so I would say most every
investigator I've worked with follows
this formula first of all you want to
immediately a define the problem or the
critical need that you're addressing and
the gaps and knowledge that you're
filling this is a short background
leading up to the stated problem and
knowledge gap the need the second
paragraph shows you how to fill that
need the solution to the stated problem
by proposing hypotheses the third
paragraph are your aims your objectives
that test that hypothesis and address
the critical need and the fourth is
probably the most important paragraph
and the one that is most often botched
or excluded is the payoff so the NIH is
going to give you two million dollars
tell me how it's going to help the
research what do you expect to find and
that leads to impact in the field and I
will say is it addressing an NIH need so
I'm gonna talk a little bit about this
but the NIH is looking for research that
is filling some of their interests not
necessarily yours and there are quite a
few requests for applications or program
announcements at the NIH puts out in
each Institute that they say we are
interested in in in finding out the
answer to these problems or this is an
area of research we want to be funding I
mean you may be putting in an
unsolicited grant which means it's your
research but it's very important that
you look first to see if it aligns in
any way shape or form to the NIH
interest I'm going to talk a little bit
about that but that's very important to
the NIH and the impact what is the
problem
your study will be successful and exert
a powerful sustained influence on the
field in a specific and maybe a more
general way and you know if it won't
work if your study you know is not
successful it will have no impact even
if it has high significance in other
words it's an important study
so the important last paragraph
addresses the expected outcomes if it's
an NIH need and what is the impact and
that those sentences are probably some
of them among the most important parts
in a specific aims page
so essentially the first paragraph of
the aims goes into what don't we know
what do we know and what don't we know
and what gap in knowledge is there
between those two things
what is the unmet medical need what is
what is what is a gap of knowledge and
that is the basis for your project
that's an oversimplification but it's
really at a very fundamental level that
is exactly what they want to know
so the first paragraph I don't like to
think of writing a grant or a paper as
fiction although in many cases they have
read some fiction you need to hook your
reader just like you would need to hook
an editor of a novel
in the very first sentence what is known
what's unknown leading to the gap and
many investigators unfortunately fall
into the trap of framing the problem of
few studies have been done or there's
not a lot of research that has been
published or that the disease itself is
the problem it's really the gap and
knowledge for diagnosing or treating the
disease that you know at the NIH is the
most fundamental level so for example
for our grant to the diabetes and
digestive and kidney diseases NIDDK on
wound healing okay
you would not write something like
little research has been done there is
need for additional work no publications
a big examine the reasons for etc the
NIH doesn't want to read this they also
don't want to read an introduction on
wound healing to type 2 diabetes affects
more than 12% of the population
responsible for 100,000 deaths and 1
million dollars in direct healthcare
cost etc etc it isn't the problem the
problem is is different for us for
example for a request for application by
the niddk on wound healing might look
like this and excuse me for reading this
but I think it's important to get the
flavor of this the cellular molecular
mechanisms underpinning tissue repair
and failure of wounds to heal are poorly
understood still and current therapies
are limited because of that poor wound
healing after trauma surgery acute
illness or chronic disease conditions
affects millions worldwide every year
and the consequences of poorly regulated
elements of healthy tissue repair
response including inflammation
angiogenesis matrix deaths of deposition
and cell recruitment failure of one or
several of these processes linked to an
underlying clinical conditions such as
vascular disease diabetes or aging which
were all frequently associated with
healing pathologies
search for clinical strategies that
would improve the body's repair
mechanisms is needed to be based on
understanding of the biology of a wound
repair and regeneration the central goal
of this research now that maybe it's in
a little general but it captures the
flavor of tell me what we do and don't
know and sort of where the gap is and
why it's important to fill that gap so
that's what you need to focus on in
paragraph one
so for example if it's a if it's a grant
identifying lymph node metastases in
patients with resectable lung cancer you
would not write in the first sentence
lung cancer is the leading cause of
cancer death among men and women in the
United States in 2008 109 thousand six
hundred forty three men were diagnosed
with lung cancer and 88 thousand three
hundred twenty nine died in addition
ninety eight thousand eight hundred and
ninety three women etc etc you don't
want to read that this is not something
that is important if the focus of the
grant is identifying metastases in the
lymph in patients with respectable lung
cancer because it states the obvious
it's not focused about the grant it
doesn't tell you what the grant is about
you want to read something more like
this failure to identify regional lymph
node metastases in 40,000 US patients a
year with surgically resected lung
cancer is associated with three with a
three-fold increase in cancer recurrence
and decreased overall survival our
research will develop model novel
methods to identify and treat lymph node
metastasis this is focused on the
problem of the grant and identifies it
and it relates to the and hopefully will
relate to the mission of the agency this
was actually taken from a grant to the
National Cancer Institute
paragraphs of your specific games the
solution to the stated problem in
filling the gap leading leading to your
aims in it it must be hypothesis based
so what is your objective with a
specific application addressing the
critical need are you developing a map
of wound microenvironment leading to
biomarkers of healing status I mean what
is the objective
you should also state what sort of this
long-term goal that you identify you
might want to say we're developing
effective biomarkers of wound healing
and identified treatments that target
each your research is not in a vacuum
it's a continuum and so five years from
now you're hopefully going to be
thinking about what you're what where
you're going with this
so the second paragraph should state a
hypothesis of your research it's
compatible of course with all known
facts and evidence that you've presented
it's very specific and it's testable so
your aims will test it and you can write
it in the form of if we hypothesize that
or specific aim one could say to test
the hypothesis that but I like the first
one to state the hypothesis and it
should be formulated through existing
literature in your preliminary findings
what you already know what you found and
what what has been found by others
the third paragraph for the specific
games as I mentioned they must be based
on hypotheses or their testing the
hypothesis that you stated they address
the problem and fill the gap that you've
identified in paragraph one they are
specific I don't want to be glib about
this but I mean a lot of a mess I've
read are not specific they must be
measurable and doable in the time frame
of the grant one of the biggest reasons
grants fail is that they are overly
ambitious the reviewers like what they
read they think it's a really
significant problem but it's too
ambitious they'll say well they'll never
get there there's no way in four years
or five years they'll get to that point
so that's important
and I don't say these things a vacuum
I've read many many grants that have
aims that start out like to study the
effects of to explore the reasons for to
better understand to investigate the
causes you know to research why this is
vague and nonspecific
you would never want to write that your
specific game should see say something
like this measure levels of calcium and
magnesium in the wound microenvironment
over 21 days in an established rodent
wound-healing model something of that
nature it's very specific it's
measurable it's specific and you then go
on to describe very briefly how you were
going to do that
the fourth paragraph which I said is the
most important or what am I expected
outcomes and what is the probability my
study will be successful in and exert a
sustained influence on the fields and
specifically more generally that's the
impact so this is the NIH payoff why
should they give you money for this
research they want to know these things
it's very important that you tell them
accurately the expected outcomes must be
specific and credible and because it's
it's the return on investment for the
NIH and you would not write this is what
we believe we will have accomplished but
we expect to determine you have to be
strong direct present tense and how will
these stated outcomes fill the need and
thereby advance research and the mission
of the agency if possible it's very
important that you write a an impact
statement that is credible specific
enough for them to believe you and that
you've really thought through how it's
going to impact research in the future
so a little bit about what this word
impact means it's the likelihood or
probability for the project to exert the
powerful influence the likelihood is
derived from you the investigator your
approach what you've found already and
the environment that you're using so
that's like they're you know they're
pretty likely to find the answer to
those and get information that's useful
this sustained powerful influence is
derived also it's derived from the
significance and innovation that you
stated in your grant and the research
fields that you refer to may vary so be
clear on what specific fields you
believe are influenced by your project
it could be very specific for example if
you're studying autism disorder but in
general you're studying other childhood
disorders with with with brain
disorganization such as Klinefelter's
syndrome or Turner's or something of
that nature
it could also be more general for those
conditions or other fields so it's very
important that you think about what
research fields are involved in in your
research so
if you if you go back and you look at
the specific games page it it looks like
this at a very high level what is the
problem
what is the gap in knowledge the
critical need that we're addressing what
is the proposed solution hypothesis what
are my aims what are my objectives and
what am i expected outcomes and impact
and long term goals and this feeds
directly back to the knowledge gap in
critical need that you stated in
paragraph 2 paragraph 1 so that that's
kind of a capture of what the aims page
should look like and now I'll give you
wording from an actual grant that I
think captures these things first is
these titles that are in gold letters
are not part of the grant but I put them
there just to show you what parts I've
been discussing screening for colon
cancer includes screening colonoscopies
for everyone over 50 but they're
expensive and invasive screening for
occult blood and stool is inexpensive
but ineffective and many cancers are
missed a blood test that could actually
detect colon cancer very early would
save lives
I've truncated this to some extent but
it gives you the flavor this actually
was a grant that eventually led to the
production of Cola guard which is a very
popular colon cancer screening test even
though it doesn't use blood ok what are
the gaps in knowledge current approaches
for measuring proteins and blood are
relatively inexpensive and insensitive
and unlikely to detect cancers early
human variability and low signal means
many independent patient samples must be
measured
what is our solution new proteomic
technologies developed by my group both
offer sensitivity and throughput needed
to identify and validate blood
biomarkers for early detection we
hypothesize that colon cancers can be
more effectively detected using
sensitive biomarkers and then this is
where they list the aims and I'm not
going to read this
but they're very very specific to
identify plasma proteins associated with
early stages to carry out a
bioinformatic analysis of
over-represented proteins for enrichment
of specific functions and to select and
validate candidate biomarkers the one
point I'm making with this slide is to
notice how short the description is of
each one of these aims the biggest
mistake I've seen in writing a specific
aims page and by the way it's only one
page 11 point typed with a 1/2 inch
margins is that they give way too much
detail under each aim and this needs to
be short one or two sentences at the
most so so that it doesn't the while it
gives the flavor it does not have to
give all the detail of each aim how
they're going to accomplish it and
here's the end the end paragraph the end
product of this research will be an
affordable accurate blood test for early
detection of colon cancer without
colonoscopy our approach will use many
previously selected methods see our
preliminary studies in the grant to
increase the probability of success
successful demonstration is project in
colon cancer will enable application
through other cancers in need of early
detection biomarkers future directions
also include the application of
assistance biology approach to the large
datasets generated in our discovery
phase that will provide new insights
about the earliest stages of colon
cancer developing such a novel treatment
for colorectal cancer directly addresses
one National Cancer Institute
provocative question and as a central
mission of the National Institute of
Diabetes and digestive and kidney
diseases so I'm not going to go into
what those are but this shows that they
have looked up requests for applications
from these Institute's or on the
strategy page of these Institute's it's
actually been stated so it's very
important that you include that if it is
directly linked
any Institute requests for proposals or
their their mission that's that's vital
and I'm going to talk about that in a
minute most of the problems with the
aims that are seen in review are that
first of all they're just lack of
original or innovative ideas that
they're unrealistic or unfocused that's
a real big one because many that I've
seen just aren't focused clearly focused
and they aren't realistic there are too
many risks there risks they need to be
justified why it's important to pursue
and how knowledge would move the field
forward of theme wasn't met they are
poorly justified so the relationship to
what is known and what is unknown is not
obvious it's got to be obvious and in a
lot of times they are hypothesis driven
they're purely descriptive and the
reviewers on certain review forums have
come back with statements like this this
proposal looks more like a collection of
experiments in which the applicant are
simply listing experience according to
their expertise in specific techniques
instead of testing and underlying
hypothesis or our enthusiasm was
dampened by a lack of hypothesis driven
by a specific mechanism other problems
lack of cohesiveness that you know the
aims have to be team attica ly related
and form a unit which would be unified
by a central hypothesis or that one aim
is dependent upon the other so if aim
one is not met you couldn't go to aim
too so you want to avoid unit dependent
of the aims unless there is no doubt
that the early goal will be achieved
that's really important
describing techniques is a problem too
many details as I mentioned and then
also I've mentioned this in an ro1
four-year grant two to four aims if
you're doing a small grant ro3 or our 21
is one to two aims otherwise it'll give
the reviewer the impression
unfocused and you know it's very
important that you avoid trying to make
this thing way too ambitious I've seen
even ro1 grants with three or four aims
and then as they went into the approach
they listed some aim one sub aim one be
subway sub aim one c1 d1 e1 on and on
and by the time I finished reading it it
was over sixty names so I said well the
reviewers are just not going to find us
doable
there's two ambitions and then the other
one is seems obvious but it's that
there's no significant impact on the
field that hasn't been stated clearly
but you really haven't thought through
what that impact will be if you don't
believe me here's an animal of internal
medicine study that showed that of 66
grants submitted to the NIH almost half
had over stated goals they were overly
ambitious they were unrealistic 38% were
poorly focused and adequately
conceptualized in half had no clear
hypothesis so that's really important
that you you know that you don't
overstate your goals your your your
realistic it's not too ambitious it's
clearly hypothesized and it's focused
that that's extremely important the rest
of the part of the grant that I
mentioned earlier is the research
strategy which is significance
innovation and approach those three
sections and the approach includes the
preliminary studies and in every Arwen
grant because an ro1 is usually
submitted by a more established
investigator it's not a grant for a
brand new investigator if you're a
postdoc and you say well I want to get
money for my research but I don't have a
great deal of preliminary studies that
would not be the grant to go for so
preliminary studies are a part of a big
part of this grant so that goes into the
approach so I'm going to talk about each
of these specific areas
first of all significance why is my work
important
and the NIH asks in this very language
for the the three things explain the
importance of the problem of a critical
barrier to the progress in the field
that you're addressing and I mentioned
that so this is really kind of the heart
of what what what you know what is the
importance of this problem
how will the proposed project improve
scientific knowledge technical
capability or clinical practice in one
or more broad fields and this speaks a
little bit this in three speak more to
the impact
describe how the concepts methods
technologies treatment services are
preventative interventions that drive
this field will be changed if the
proposed aims are achieved so they want
to know how is it going to be innovative
and change some of these paradigms and
ways of doing things how you deliver how
a method is done or you know a new
technology or new treatment or service
how is that going to change if if you
achieve your aims the biggest problems
with the significance is as I mentioned
earlier and I'll only repeat it because
it's happened so many times you don't
want to argue that a particular illness
is significant that states the obvious
the significance is what you will do to
overcome the problems and diagnosis or
treatment and that you know it's just
low impact research it's just
incremental it's confirmatory as
duplicitous I mean it's obviously this
has got to be something new something
that you're addressing that has not been
looked at before that high significance
now the innovation which is the second
part of the research strategy is
probably the most problematic for all
most investigators because they don't
understand what it is and I'm going to
try to clear that up first of all these
are the three things right out of the
instructions of the NIH NIH instructions
the sf-424 explain how the application
challenges and seeks to shift current
research or clinical practice paradigm
describe any nominal theoretical
concepts approaches methods
instrumentation interventions to be
developed or used and any advantage over
existing methodologies instrumentation
or interventions so there it's important
that if you are proposing something
innovative something new you're doing
something different a new a new canoe
method or a new instrument or new
intervention that you describe why
you're using it and what advantage do
you think this is going to have over
current interventions or instrumentation
or methods
and then the third thing is explained
refinements improvements or new
applications of theoretical concepts
approaches or methodologies
instrumentation or interventions okay so
that may not clear it up for for people
who are listening to this but I would
recommend that you go on and I'll show
you in a minute how to get there to the
nai NIAID website and there are actual
full grant applications and you should
read innovation sections to see how
people describe how why their research
is innovative you need to understand
what innovation means for an NIH grant
application and what the reviewers are
looking for so it's important to realize
that research does not necessarily have
to create a brand new paradigm it can be
shifting a current paradigm slightly it
can offer new combination of known
methods leading to a new perspective it
could refine an existing model or
technology so it and also it's important
to realize that it's less risky to use
an innovative approach to solve an
existing problem than to take on a
problem that's highly innovative it can
be hard to gain acceptance by the
reviewers if your ideas are outside the
mainstream especially if you're left
less experienced if your proposal is
highly innovative you'll need to make a
strong case for why you're challenging
the existing paradigm and have data to
support that one of the things that is
important for the NIH is if you're
suggesting something novel something new
a new way of doing something a new way
of looking at something that you may
bring in consultants many different
consultants that will help you with that
with expertise that you don't you don't
have that's that's important but because
innovation is a review criterion you
want to show how you will break new
ground so it's a kind of a balance the
last part is how you're going to do this
research what if I
already found is your preliminary
studies and how will I accomplish my
specific games so this is the NIH
wording out of the sf-424 what is the
strategy methods analysis you're going
to use to accomplish the aims
how will you collect analyze and
interpret your data and as well as any
research sharing plans as appropriate
and then they want you to address any
potential problems alternative
strategies and benchmarks for success
anticipated to achieve the aims this is
important because if you don't recognize
that there could be pitfalls in your
research and how you would get around
that it doesn't appear that you've
thought it through and especially if the
projects in the early stages of
development you want to describe any
strategy to establish feasibility and
address high management of the high-risk
aspects of the work and again the ways
you would do that is to use a lot of
consultants and have expertise in the
field and details on how you're going to
establish feasibility of doing this work
it you have to convince them that you
can do it we're not going to give you
money on some vague notion that they
think well he might be able to get there
but it's important that they are feeling
very confident you're going to
accomplish that aim so the approach
would contain such things as your
preliminary studies your progress report
you know call the minerals as well your
study design your study strategy your
experimental approach so experiments to
address he chain and and they're listed
by aims so you have to list unless there
are common methods that you're going to
use in every Aang but every aim will
have a specific strategy so experiments
that will address each aim and I would
really recommend that you think visually
and thinking about tables figures to
illustrate complex experiments with
multiple arms repetition under
different conditions for example I'll
give you an example of how I used that
in one of the grants I helped to write
and that's right here so this is a grant
that was at a Dartmouth gut funded as an
ro1
about addressing the problem RSA
methicillin-resistant Staph step and
[Music]
this investigator was doing a five lab
with a multi Pi study and their five
labs involved and he wrote three pages
of very complex methodology of workflow
among the five collaborating environment
laboratories and I said we're going to
reduce this down to one page with a
diagram and I put together a diagram
with him and while he wrote that put
together the diagram it clarified his
thinking about how he's going to
accomplish this and that really was
useful by just simply diagramming it so
we came up with this diagram with
numbers and each number corresponding to
a step in the in the method so it was
judged on review by the NIH as not only
they're using in each lab tried and
tested and published result
I mean methods but this series of
workflow this this workflow um is in the
way this these these compounds would go
through each lab was very unique and
innovative so they viewed it as highly
innovative this has never been done
before but it's being done by lab as the
flow has never been done but it's being
done by labs and then are you that have
tested their methods so this got very
high marks the approach and I recommend
that you think about doing this when
you're writing anything involving
research is to diagram it
also as I mentioned in the approach you
want to be put in pitfalls an
alternative approach you know what are
your roadblocks if you don't see the
weak points then reviewers think your
approaches care less and less likely to
succeed and if you're a new stage p.i or
early stage P I I mentioned that only
established guys but if you're early in
your established career strategy to
establish the feasibility with the
methods a new investigator has given
leeway with some aspects of grant but
such as Plamen or Dale but not with the
approach anticipated results and lack of
plans for possible problems so that's
important to remember
common errors in this area is too much
detail so what happens as you know I
don't know how many years ago what ten
years ago they changed the grant from 25
pages to 12 that upset a great deal of
investigators because they said well
there's no way in God's green earth I
can write an ro1 research strategy in 12
pages well trust me people learn how to
do it and what happens though is
starting with a blinking cursor which is
something you should never do getting
through the approach say 3/4 of the way
and say oh my god I only have one and a
half more pages that I can put in here
and for more diagrams and I can't get to
the last name so they start truncating
the information and the grant looks like
a patchwork of lots of information less
information and just deep you know
outlined information so I'm going to
tell you to outline your grant at the
end of this lecture but the level of
detail should be consistent and it
should be proportional to the novelty of
the method standard techniques should
not have a lot of detail you can
reference or show that in preliminary
studies feasibility of each aim is not
shown so listing your experiments
without tying them to the aims will just
stop your grant
we'll just kill it the research is not
targeted to NIH interest there's a lack
of pitfalls and alternative approaches
you've got to include those you know
being able to propose alternative
approaches if your aims are your plans
fails it scores big with reviewers they
want to see that overly ambitious as I
mentioned this is not a wish list for
experiments that you think are
impressive if the studies are not
achievable in the time frame of the
grant this it may become future work but
you don't propose work that is clearly
more than four years so the the overall
impact score you get at a 50,000 foot
view is why is my research important
plus can I do it and I qualified to do
it and will it have a significant impact
in the field and then I said it before
is really what the bottom line is for
reviewer looking at your research and
you know I get to the point that I made
earlier Jane Scott program officer at
the National Heart and Lung Blood
Institute said what reviewer the reason
for a reviewers lack of enthusiasm on a
grant is often that it does not address
the primary scientific mission or
interest of the funding agency and
people say well I'm submitting an
unsolicited grant of course it wouldn't
well but it should it should and I'm
going to show you how to how to look at
that unfortunately a lot of
investigators haven't been shown how to
do this in the grand targets the NIH or
so on the specific aims page significant
an approach you want to use specific
language such as our proposal addresses
three objectives of the National Cancer
Institute request for applications see a
1500 eight now this may be in other
words you would be directly applying for
that RFA or these specific aims address
two objectives of the National Institute
of General Medical Sciences namely the
research is in direct response to the
NIH brain strategic initiative so it's
really important that you tie it to what
NIH is looking for
okay and there's three ways to do this
the first is each Institute has stated
research priorities they also have
requests for funding and program
announcements are a phase and pas and I
said earlier the NIH reporter is a tool
online tool that show you what has been
funded so first let's take a look at
here's the in a National Heart Lung and
Blood Institute a huge huge NIH agency
and within there here are the funding
areas heart lung blood sleeves sickle
cell disease implementation science etc
etc if you click on any one of those it
will show you a whole list of research
priorities funding areas that they're
interested in these are not our FTE
should not request for applications but
areas that they are interested in any
investigator who is submitting work to
the NIH must read this first so that
they can align what they're doing with
some of the work that the NIH is doing
or they're interested in here's one from
the National Institute of Allergy and
Infectious Diseases areas of study it's
amazing to me that a lot of
investigators never even look at this so
hiv/aids infectious diseases allergy
immunology and transplantation etc these
are general but within each one of these
is a specific list of things that they
are interested in funding that's very
important that you know that RFA is
request for funding request for
application so if you go to the National
Cancer Institute and you click on grants
and training you will get this okay
you'll see areas like research grant
funding funding for training cancer
moonshot funding latest program
announcements and you should go through
all of those sections if you're
submitting say a cancer related that you
think would be directly related to the
to the NCI and you may find that it
isn't but related directly to the NCI
and read what the RFA czar
okay and read what sort of areas that
are interested in funding because this
gives you a you know direct insight into
what they're looking for as I mentioned
the NIH reporter if you type in NIH
reporter in Google you'll find it and
the query page looks like this it's what
they used to call in a crisp database
which was a very poor version of this
this is an extremely powerful tool you
can search all funded NIH and I believe
there are other federal agency funded
grants they're funded and you can look
at it by researcher and organization you
can look at by a string of text a logic
text using and or you can look into
application numbers if you have if you
happen to have that you can look at and
the one I have circled in red here is
important you can look at it by agency
you can look at it by funding mechanism
only ro ones only training grants only
career awards whatever they might be you
can also at the very bottom there it's a
study section you can find every study
section for every at the NIH and look at
what they fund so if you know that your
grant may be likely looked at it for a
specific study section look up and see
what they've already funded it'll give
you a clue as to what they're interested
in that's very important the other thing
that you should do is go to the NIAID
and here's the website and there they
give you sample applications for ro ones
which is the full application and the
summary statement here are three of them
they also show our twenty ones and I
think career Awards okay I'm going to
talk at the very end here about some
very well-known peer reviewers
that our institutions who have spent
many years reviewing grants and here is
some of their advice
the most common error particularly with
new investigators is over ambitiousness
covering too much territory with the
time allotted this is Keith Yamamoto
he's the chair of the University of
California School of Medicine and this
is probably one of the most big the
biggest problems of grants fail overly
ambitious okay Martin Philbert at
University of Michigan if you do not
immediately convey the essence of the
idea clearly then no matter how good the
idea it's lost convey clearly
repetitively what you want to do why
it's important and how it'll advance the
science okay and and if you it's in two
or three sentences you cannot convey
that and you you have to really go back
and rethink what your research is about
it's very important to be able to answer
those questions and this is the one I
like the most David Granger at the
University of Utah said you can read
many proposal but one stands out as
being a wonderful piece of writing for
me these contain a lucid style a
compelling scientific look you create
creative idea and especially this idea
of impact moving the science forward
towards a clinical end that is credible
with a boost of capability to a patient
population with an unmet need and I
think that succinctly describes what the
impact is and that has to be extremely
clear in your proposal Brian Hoffman at
Northwestern University says if you have
a bunch of peer reviewers looking at
your proposal they want to find an
exciting idea in good science that is
supported so tell them a good story
they're interested in reading what you
have to say
now here are some grant reviewers they
will be unnamed but this is some of the
things that they've said when they
reread proposals and I've been among
these psychological mechanisms came into
play during the review of the grant once
I lost patience for an applicant for
running disorganized section it was much
more likely to notice other faults once
they they hit a red flag this is true
and I can tell you from experience of a
peer reviewer you know in a journal or
journal editor once they see problems
they're going to start seeing other
faults also when the proposal is sloppy
it was difficult not to extrapolate that
to sloppy lab work but the other
extremely is here the applicant made it
for me to get the information necessary
to assess the application the more
likely I was if the science was sound to
have a positive feeling about the
proposal so how you write your proposal
has a huge impact on how they review it
here's another one bad organization
could mislead the reviewer if the topic
sentence the paragraphs is full of
unimportant ideas I would move on to the
next paragraph this was sometimes that's
remenham for the applicant and it's
embarrassing for me what I learned from
my peers that the important information
had been buried in one of those part of
paragraphs and I'm going to tell you to
outline your grant because this is how
you get around that okay so an outline
is considering the grant as a unit to
establish a logical progression from
specific aims through approach it'll
eliminate any disorganized or illogical
thought and poor transition it will
eliminate redundancies and omissions and
it will provide with fixed points of a
reference that reduce complex revisions
and eliminates redundancies it'll force
you to be brief clear and cohesive if
you start writing a grant and you
haven't thought through clearly what
you're going to say and you have no
outline I guarantee you 100% that you'll
run into trouble with many of these
things it'll be too redundant it'll have
things that are missing it will all be
unclear it
be overly clunky and very difficult to
read and it won't be cohesive and these
are all things that a grant must have to
be compete successfully so I would just
suggest that you like number the
headings help reviewers navigate like
3.0 3.1 but not 3.0 point one point two
point five this is not a well it was a
government document but it's written for
NASA make and make the consisting is
consistent throughout I mean I've read
many many grants where I couldn't follow
through the grant what the headings were
and that they were inconsistent in terms
of what level they were when you want to
emphasize something don't bold it or
underline it probably not italicize it
either worst of all don't bold italicize
or underline it in different ways in
different places that'll really confuse
the reviewer and I like minor the person
I learned to write grants from at
Stanford told me at the end of your
paragraph tell the reviewer in a very
short little summary statement what
you've just told them just to give them
a summary and again tables of timelines
figures of approach help a great deal
for the reviewers what a reviewer or
anybody sees versus what they read they
retain what they see much more often
here's a picture of a grant from a
successful grant and nicely laid out so
this helps also psychologically you can
see that all the figures are in a box
the image of the figure titles are
within that box it's very clear
sometimes when I've seen grants where
the where the where the figures and the
figure captions and the text were very
there were all mixed together it's very
difficult to read so it's important that
the grant be put together
skillfully this way if you don't know
how to do this find somebody that knows
how to use Microsoft Word which is
really unfortunately a tragedy because
word is not made to do this it will do
it but it's hard to do
so the last thing here your grant will
address a critical unmet need in
medicine and one that the NIH wants to
fund your grant has a high impact and
it's very innovative but it'll fail
because your English is unclear the
spelling and punctuation has a bunch of
are incorrect and the writing of floppy
it's not clear - not concise or logical
so I would say that if you if writing is
not your forte get help with colleagues
who are good writers or an editor who
can help you clarify your thoughts
that's really really important so
remember that your grant your paper your
post or your PowerPoint presentation is
often the only representation of your
work that the critics and reviewers who
fund your research published your
finding or judge your work will see so
you know it reflects directly on you how
you put this together this is probably
the most important part you can use
years and years and years of great
research have great ideas but if you
don't communicate it clearly it's lost
or worse reflected badly upon you
writing and communication is clear the
most valuable skill any scientists learn
if you learn how to communicate verbally
orally and write well you will move up
in your field because it's those that
communicate clearly are the ones that I
think are paying attention to the most
and the last thing is just a mention of
my company medCom consulting I started
this about eighteen nineteen years ago
after many years of work at universities
was an industry for a while and the
government it was at NASA and the Life
Sciences Division so what what we do is
regional writing editing and reviewing
of NIH and NSF NSF grants whether they
be research grant career award
training grants project grants I write
and edit and put together peer-reviewed
manuscripts as well as abstracts posters
and presentations at medical congresses
and we do the long term research funding
planning through the NIH or private
agencies as I mentioned you know things
like the National Cancer sorry the the
the American Cancer Society Alzheimer's
Association American Heart Association
you know Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation they all find millions of
dollars of research and yet a lot of
proposals that come across my desk are
not put together for ideally for that
for that agency or for the NIH and
that's what we do for for for
investigators in academia and my email
is medCom consult at gmail.com if you're
interested in reaching me and that
concludes today's lecture thank you
you
dr. dance thank you for that informative
presentation now we will start the live
Q&A portion of our webinar and if you
have liked if you have a question you'd
like to ask dr. dance please do come now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll we will answer as many of your
questions as we have climbed for okay
yesterday on our first question why did
you mention ro1 in the title won't these
strategies apply for caves or other NIH
grants well great question I wanted to
give a presentation generally about the
research grant at the NIH or the our
grant there as I mentioned many
different our grants the are one being
the most common but first of all these
strategies in terms of the review
criteria well let me let me back up the
review criteria for K grants or career a
grant that the NIH are different okay
they're not not as I stated for an our
grant K grants are our training grants
that are for postdoctoral fellows who
want to receive a number of years of
training mentored mentored training and
their grants or K grant will have a very
different section which is describes the
kennedys background and what they're
going to be doing with sorts of
weaknesses they have it will have a
research strategy and a lot of the
information I gave about research
strategy considerations what's important
will apply to a K grant but understand
that a career water a K grant is
research training and a different bent
than research grants excuse me so
don't know about other applications that
you're referring to excuse me but these
applied generally to our grants research
grants at the NIH and not other grants
such as training grants tea grants or
program grants Thank You dr. dan now
could you comment on the youth or
avoidance of abbreviation
well any abbreviations or acronyms in
the grant should always be defined first
use any any acronym no matter how
obvious they are so it's important that
those are defined right up front I don't
know what abbreviations the the
individual is asking about specifically
but acronyms always are defined first
use so don't fill your application with
a bunch of abbreviations and acronyms
that the reviewers are going to stumble
over that will be that will be a
deal-breaker
dr. Dan are do you have any
recommendations for early investigators
trying to convert a K award into an ro1
well this is the normal path isn't it
okay a K award first of all you don't
convert a K award into an r1 but during
when you write your K grant the obvious
path is to towards an ro1 so during the
discussion of your pathway in terms of
becoming an independent investigator you
refer to work that you plan to do after
the training is finished after you have
completed the K award and you have
completed your your research what you
intend to what direction you would tend
to go to in a K award I'm sorry an ro1
so that usually is mentioned in the K
award it's not converted the only well
it's not really a conversion the only
you know kind of K award that is our
sort of an our grant is the K 99 ro1
which is a very advanced K award it's
usually for people who have very very
highly experienced in the lab not quite
ready to write an ro1 so they'll write a
K 99 which is usually only three years
of mentored training and then two years
of doing actual researches in R zero
zero and those are grants that are very
prestigious there they pay quite well
and they're transferable so somebody for
example at Vanderbilt University came to
Dartmouth when I was there and he came
with a k99 rlo and he then wrote an ro1
but he used the r00 portion for two
years to you know set up the lab and get
things moving before his our ones was
funded recognized you don't you know
want to wear eight the year before
because these things sometimes take over
a couple of years to get going but the K
the K is at the you know the pathway
from a K is to
so it's always mentioned
thank you dr. Dan now let's stick with a
k99
and for those k99 grants what is the
importance of preliminary studies it's
pretty important that you have some
preliminary data because this is an
advanced que award and I didn't really
intend for this lecture to be about
career Awards but since you asked it is
one of the most important aspects of an
epic k99 is that you have preliminary
studies usually a k99 recipient has done
you know several years of research
already usually through a t32 training
grant or FF grant a fellowship or some
other mechanism and has gained a fair
amount of preliminary studies for the K
so they're k99 already is advanced that
they're saying well there's two or three
areas that are important that I I need
training and here's what they are and
here's my plan to get that training and
here's my research that will also give
me a fair amount of background and
training to that end but they have a
preliminary study section in their
research strategy that that has to be
there the same is true in our 21 a lot
of people think I was just a you know a
beginning our grant I can write that
before the r1 that is not a beginning
grant a lot of preliminary studies go on
that so the K 99 the KO one which would
be a you know just a general research
grant for a trainee that is probably has
far less you know need for any
preliminary studies the k99 is more of
an advance of grant and has to have
preliminary studies
now speaking of the ro1 dr. dan what are
the chances to get funded for a good r1
application if the applicant has no
previous training grant award no
previous training grants awards record
well an r1 you don't need to have a
training grant to you know to to to
write an ro1 you could have come through
a lab that you know the P AI has a you
know a long history of funded our ones
are you know a couple of RO ones and the
the postdoctoral fellow could spend
three or four years working with that
investigator and not and get get their
training off not from a K or but through
just being on the RO one is say a
co-investigator some other collaborator
and get the training that way in terms
however of doing your own research of
the investigator would require that you
sort of break off into a separate you
know area of the research which has to
be distinct from theirs although it may
be in the same field and then they may
be eligible for an ro1 although the
majority of investigators who who go to
ro1s are coming from a k award so if you
don't have any preliminary as data or
preliminary studies from it from a k
it's harder to gain acceptance but the
bottom line is if you do have some data
and it's your own data and you've done
the work then certainly you can apply
for an r1 as a new investigator although
most are ones are written by more
established investigators
dr. Dan what is the maximum number of
investigators in an ro1 proposal and I
know the answer to that I'm sorry I I
mean first of all there's one principal
investigators and a number of
co-investigators and you have to read
the the you have to read the the
unsolicited I gave you the numbers RFA
for the for the unsolicited are Owen
grant to see what the rules on that are
I don't know what they are but I pretty
sure they're probably no more than four
or five but that's different than having
but that's different than having
collaborators so a collaborator is
somebody usually in another institution
that is adding expertise to your to your
grant so you may have not a lot of
expertise in a particular methodology
and are using a collaborator
co-investigators usually somebody who
has a major role in the grant and
there's usually rules for that and they
all have to submit biosketches
thank you now dr. Dan could you
elaborate on writing out benchmarks in
the approach section for for an example
you know benchmarks and the approach
okay well a lot of grants require that
bigger grants you know the multi PI
grants do require that a lot of requests
for applications from the NIH for sayyou
grants which are cooperative agreements
with the NIH require benchmarks and ro1
does not and I can tell you what not to
do please do not put a box together
saying m1 m2 m3 and then to the right of
that year 1 year 2 year 3 year 4 and
just put a checkmark that that is that
probably will sink your grant when an
investigator would have went to review
receives that each of the aims should
you should have thought through what
steps are required to get to that aim to
get to that endpoint and a lot of times
investigators I just reviewed a grant
yesterday that had three specific games
but each of the aims had three sub aims
so they broke down the the objectives
for that aim into smaller you know
stepwise pieces and those went into a
benchmarks those are the benchmarks for
success and those were then broken out
as to when they would think they would
accomplish those putting down things
like writing a paper you know applying
for another grant or anything as those
are benchmarks benchmarks are the
specific objectives the specific points
at which you feel you're going to get to
to get to the next point in that aim so
you have to really think that through
and it's a very good thing to put in
there if you have the room you only have
12 pages because it gives the reviewer a
lot of confidence that you've thought
through how you're going to do this work
and it will summarise in some ways the
work for them
I've seen a lot of benchmarks that are
very poorly put together and not thought
through and that would be worse than
even putting one in thank you now we
have so many great questions coming in
and I want to remind our audience that
those questions we do not have time to
answer today and those coming in during
the on-demand period will be answered by
dr. dan via the the contact information
that you provided at the time of
registration now it's time for a few
more doctor dance can you explain a
little bit more on ro1 ro3 and r21 in
terms of preliminary data required well
I already mentioned this and the r21
does require preliminary need well let
me put it this way if you read the RFA
or you read the unsolicited instructions
for an r21 grant it'll say in there
somewhere that no preliminary data is
required but some of the Institute's did
a study a number of years ago and I have
a lecture on this that I present and
they showed that the vast majority of
accepted our twenty ones had preliminary
data okay so that means that that's what
they want to see they want to see some
preliminary data but understand that our
21 grant is not a you know a lot of
people think of it as well I'll write
the r21 first and then I'll go to the r1
it is not a preliminary step to the r1
it is not a mini ro1 it is an
exploratory grant so it's a two-year
grant generally speaking it's it's for
in going into unexplored areas that that
have not been looked at now does that
mean you mean generally would think well
that doesn't require preliminary data
but you really do need to have some
background to get to that point why are
you looking at this unexplored area what
are the what are the areas that you've
already seen and what and even if it's
unpublish what have you done so it does
require and I think that it would be
much more likely to be funded with whip
limit or data an ro3 much less so
but now that an RL tree which is sort of
a it very few first of all not all
agencies 21 agencies at the NIH the
Institute sorry well fund an ro1 I'm
sorry the fund in our 21 or an ro3 and
RL tree is even less accepted by many
institutes you have to look at the RO 3
what they call the unsolicited you know
RFA it's a tower of a number and read it
and see which agencies are accepted
accept that there are certain actual
requests for applications or parent
announcements that are those RFA's that
for 21 there are o 3s but not very many
ro 3 is a very small grant usually for
two years $50,000 and it's some it is
generally doesn't require a preliminary
data is to look at a explore you know an
area that you just need some preliminary
data and it may be a good grant for a
new investigator to start out just to
gather some information but again it's
very very limited our own ones are far
more accepted and and common at the NIH
and you have to look that up you have to
look up the RFA you have to look up the
you know the the unsolicited are they
number to get the information on those
now dr. dance there is a perception that
NIH proposals are not expected to be as
hypothesis-driven as they were in the
past for example some form of omics
fishing expedition is more accepted
these days did you give us our opinion
on that well I don't know where this
individual has ever gotten this
information but I can tell you that that
is completely false if you if you go out
with a series of experiments that are
not based on any hypothesis or a
thought-out
problem that is very specific that
you're testing you're going to get
turned down my opinion is that you will
get turned down if you write a bunch of
fixing fishing expedition proposals
based on you know experiments that you'd
like to do the NIH is looking for
research that is hypothesis based I know
that for an absolute fact and I've never
heard that NH proposals are today more
less hypothesis driven that's just not
true it's not is not true based on many
of the people at the NIH I know and I've
talked to and it's not true based on
many of the investigators that I work
with who who write proposals so if
you're writing an ro1 you have to have a
hypothesis that that is shown I showed
you many slides that and even research
that backs that up dr. ján we're almost
out of time we're going to end with this
question and can you describe more about
what the benefits and disadvantages are
for r21 yeah well let me you know it is
it's kind of a long answer I would
recommend that you go online to the NIH
and type in r21 Anjali
fitted RFA you'll find you'll find with
the the parent announcement that's what
they're called and this is what you
apply for if your if your grant is
unsolicited that means it is not you're
not applying to a particular RFA and
read let that grant what that r21 the
purpose is it's a very very specific
purpose it's it's an exploratory grant
and it is very different than an ro1 ro1
is it much more you know first of all
it's looking at a much bigger problem
it's looking at something that's going
to go for years and our 21 goes to years
the the grant the are 21 grand is as I
mentioned is not a many ro1 is not a
preliminary step to an r1 but it
looking at areas of research that have
been completely unexplored I realized
the era one is going into innovative
areas but the r21 is looking at a
specific and usually much narrower
problem that's unexplored and you're
going into this with with the
understanding that you know these are
areas that have not been looked at
before you wanting to try and take a
very narrow problem and look at it and
it is written in a different way even
though the structure of the r21 is
identical to an ro1 the only difference
is on the r21 and the RL 3 you only have
six pages not 12 to write your research
strategy the much more narrow grant and
it has usually only one or two aims but
I recommend to get a complete answer on
that is to go to the art you just type
in our 21 NIH and you'll find usually
the unsolicited you know parent
announcement which has a very specific
wording from the NIH and then if you go
to the NIAID the National Institute of
Allergy and Infectious Diseases website
they have they have sample grants and
there are 20 wind grants in there that
you can look at to see you know the
level of detail and the kind of research
that even though it's an allergy and
infectious diseases it'll give you a
flavor for the amount of information
they are 21 you know will will will be
looked at but I can tell you that not
all Institute's accept our 21 10
solicited and it's important that you
know that before you start I've
unfortunately even for experienced
investigators have had somebody send me
a grant they said you could you look at
this is going to the NCI it's in our 21
it's looking at this particular area of
esophageal cancer and I said well yeah
and see I doesn't accept our twenty ones
that are unsolicited he was completely
unaware of that wrote this entire
proposal took him several months and he
was flabbergasted he said well what can
I do with it and I said write an ro1
based on that but which he did but you
have
rewrite it you can't just take it and
expand it you have to rewrite it it's a
different level of writing so hopefully
that helps you but I can't go into a lot
of the specifics in our 21
thank you dr. Dan now do you want any
final comments for our audience
well now III you know other than when
you you know I I wanted to emphasize the
fact that anybody doing research whether
you have written an NIH grant or trying
to write more you're considering writing
one or you've never written one you may
not write one but you write anything
about your research whether it's you
know writing up you know your the
findings from your research to present
at you know your journal club meetings
or you're a student and you have to
present in front of your your
investigator and other students to show
that you're you know the you know this
is a skill you're trying to develop or
you're going to national meetings or
you're you know writing a paper it the
considerations I gave in writing this
grant are very generalizable to those
things how do you think about why this
is an important study why is it
significant why is it new it's novel
what makes it that way and why will the
study I you know really help us move the
field forward that I am the idea of
impact that's those are the things that
you should have in your in your head at
a high level so that when you write or
give a presentation you go to a national
meeting and you're putting your slides
together put those things in there I've
gone to so many national meetings and
I've seen slides and it's just so much
gibberish and and and unfortunately a
lot of technical detail that the
audience couldn't understand and I sit
there and wonder why is this research
being done why is it important he never
explained any of that so if somebody's
going to give you money or you're going
to influence somebody you better be able
to say those things and and we used to
do a thing at Dartmouth where we would
have each investigators stand up for 10
minutes and say why am i doing a study
why is it important to me aid and tell
me why it's innovative what's new what's
exciting what hasn't been done and what
will happen once I get the answers that
I think I'll get by asking these
questions it
really helps the investigators think
through through their work thank you
doctor dancer your time today
Odell selected inqalab roots and our
sponsor like our Microsystems for
underwriting today's educational webcast
now this webcast can be viewed on demand
shortly and lab routes will alert you
via email when it is available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event thanks for
joining us and we hope to see you again
soon
have a great day
you
okay